an dänischen gehört dass kollegen
gekündigt haben jede menge leute alle
fix und fertig sind weil man ist immer
unter druck man ist immer angespannt man
hat immer das gefühl
irgendwas passiert bricht zusammen es
geht hier um leben und tod
spätestens seit der korona pandemie ist
eigentlich allen klar wir haben ein
massives problem in der pflege das wurde
gerade ja sehr deutlich ich bin aminata
belly und das hier ist kontext tiefe
zusammenhänge und fundstücke aus dem zdf
archiv ausgegraben heute zum
pflegenotstand wie konnte es überhaupt
zu notstand in der pflege kommen wir
klären die vier wichtigsten ursachen und
werfen einen blick darauf was sich
ändern muss und wie realistisch das bist
[Musik]
die aktuelle situation ist beunruhigend
für uns alle bei einer umfrage für das
zdf gaben 2021 knapp 46 prozent der
gesetzlich versicherten an dass sie sich
in bezug auf die medizinische versorgung
für die zukunft ernsthafte sorgen machen
aber es ist natürlich kein geheimnis
dass wir schon seit jahren und vor allem
auch
[Musik]
und das ist das krasse dass man einfach
schon so lange weiß dass es ein so
erheblichen personalmangel gibt schon
seit dem anfang der 1960 er jahre wird
über einen mangel an pflegepersonal
gesprochen seit den 1990 er jahren
spitzen sich die missstände zu auch 2001
wurde darüber berichtet
in die nahe zukunft eigentlich einen
großen mangel auf uns zukommen wir
werden also pflegefachkräfte brauchen
und so werden sie nicht haben und das
liegt an einem großen problem der
demografischen entwicklung in
deutschland
die geburtenrate sinkt und die
lebenserwartung steigt und ab dem achten
lebensjahr steigt eben auch die
statistische wahrscheinlichkeit rapide
an auf fremde hilfe angewiesen zu sein
welche ursachen gibt es also für den
erheblichen mangel in der pflege wir
schauen sie uns an eine der ursachen
sind die extremen arbeitsbedingungen bei
einer studie zur arbeitszufriedenheit
kam heraus dass die arbeitsbedingungen
die pflegekräfte am meisten belasten sie
führen dazu dass die abbruchquote in
pflege ausbildung überdurchschnittlich
hoch ist rund 30 prozent der
auszubildenden brechen vorzeitig ab
viele pflegekräfte die ausbildung
absolviert haben halten dem beruf dann
nicht bis zur rente durch und fast 35
der erwerbstätigen in der pflege
arbeiten in teilzeit oder sind
geringfügig beschäftigt viele geben an
dass ihnen der berufs uns zu viel wird
dann bin ich im zimmer eingegangen weil
ein patient geklingelt hatte der sehr
starke schmerzen hat ich habe keine
pflegekraft gefühl der ich bescheid
geben könnte was soll ich jetzt tun und
das habe ich dem patienten gesagt und er
war so erbost darüber und er hatte so so
dass schmerzen dass er eine glasflasche
hut genommen hat und nach mir geworfen
hat 2017 kamen in kliniken in
deutschland im schnitt 13 patientinnen
auf eine pflegefachkraft und damit hatte
deutschland unter den untersuchten
ländern den schlechtesten
personalschlüssel in den niederlanden
waren es beispielsweise nur 6,9
patientinnen pflegefachkraft durch diese
personalschlüssel stehen die
pflegekräfte konstant unter enormen
zeitdruck mein dienst war so wahnsinnig
und irgendwann habe ich an meinem
zentrale monitor draußen außerhalb des
patientenzimmers gesehen dass er
verstorben ist man hat nicht mal mehr so
viel zeit für diese grundlegenden dinge
niemand möchte so sterben es muss jedem
da draußen klar sein dass das die der
alltag in den krankenhäusern ist in
deutschland man sieht der job ist sowohl
physisch als auch psychisch anstrengend
außerdem machen pflegekräfte viele
überstunden 2016 wurden in der pflege
über 95 millionen überstunden geleistet
davon ein drittel unbezahlt dazu kommt
dass die pflegekräfte häufig im
schichtdienst arbeiten und sich job und
privatleben dadurch schlecht vereinbaren
lassen auch politische entscheidungen
haben zum personalmangel beigetragen wir
haben eine durch ökonomisierung der
medizin politisch gewollt auf den weg
gebracht und das ist die konsequenz
davon dass eben nur das gemacht wird was
geld bringt und eben ein einspardruck
über die kliniken verhängt wird mit der
folge dass eben ein personal gespart
wird weil das der größte posten ist die
privatisierung des gesundheitssystems
führte zu einem enormen kostendruck und
ist damit eine weitere hauptursache für
den notstand kritiker innen sehen eine
grundsätzliche unvereinbarkeit von
profit und patientinnen wohl konkret
werden hier vor allem seit jahren die
der gv stein kritisiert dieser 2004
verpflichten sind das hat dazu geführt
dass die krankenhäuser für jeden fall
den 7 handeln eine pauschale bekommen
was bedeutete werden ein krankenhaus das
geld ausgab für mehr ärzte dass wir mehr
geräte dann bedeutet das mehr umsatz
gabe an krankenhaus dieses geld aus für
mehr pflege bedeutet das mehrkosten aber
kein zusätzlicher umsatz daher sind
pflegekräfte abgebaut worden wir haben
50 bis 80.000 pflegekräfte in der
krankenhauspflege verlor rang durch
diese maßnahme ein weiterer grund für
den personalmangel hat ebenfalls mit
geld zu tun es sind die zu niedrigen
löhne zum vergleich das monatliche
durchschnittsgehalt der
vollzeitbeschäftigten arbeitnehmer in
deutschland lag 2020 beiden
3975 euro brutto gesundheits und
krankenpfleger innen verdienen
durchschnittlich 3000 578 euro brutto im
monat fachkräfte im pflegeheim kamen auf
durchschnittlich 3300 63 euro jenen
altenheim auf 3291 rückenhalt ist als
eher niedrig also gemessen an den
leistungen die wir bringen müssen und
auch von den bedingungen die das zweite
wochenende arbeiten keine schichtzulage
hier eine uniklinik und einfach was
attraktiv besuchen wenn in diesem
beitrag aus den 80er jahren bis heute
journals in voller länge sehen wollt
dann empfehle ich die zdf mediathek
ein grund für das niedrige gehalt ist
dass viele pflegekräfte nicht
gewerkschaftlich organisiert sind und
dass pflegeberufe weiter dominiert sind
und lange zeit so genannte zu verdienen
darin berufe waren frauen dominierte
berufe werden bei gleichwertigen
anforderungen fast durchgängig
schlechter bezahlt als männerberufe aber
hier geht es letztlich um die frage ob
der verdienst im vergleich zur leistung
angemessen ist und wie wichtig der beruf
für uns als gesellschaft ist ich habe
manchmal das gefühl dass die menschen
verdrängen dass sie auch selbst
irgendwann auf pflege
sein könnten wie ist es bei euch habt
ihr euch auch schon mal mit dem thema
beschäftigt vielen pflegekräften geht es
aber gar nicht nur ums gehalt sie stört
auch die geringe gesellschaftliche
anerkennung und wertschätzung letztlich
bist du dich ausführende hans der
mediziner und die medizin ordnet an aber
es gibt ja viel weniger mediziner vor
ort als als pflegekräfte und so ist es
letztlich auch in den pflegeheimen und
ambulanten diensten du bist alleine mit
dem patienten und du musst die sachsen
haben und sie haben häufig keine zeit
mehr für die patienten und
pflegebedürftigen obwohl sie ja gerade
deswegen den beruf ergriffen haben ich
glaube eine sache wurde deutlich mit
klatschen und keksen ist es nicht getan
es muss ich wirklich einfach sein wir
müssen mehr mitarbeiter in die
ausbildung kriegen zur gesundheits und
krankenpflege und die rahmenbedingungen
müssen verbessert werden um mitarbeiter
im beruf zu halten einer der ersten
elementaren schritte ist ist die
vergütung von pflegefachpersonen in
einen versorgungsgebieten auf einen
grund niveau von 4000 euro anzuheben
dazu brauchen wir aber auch eine
perspektive in der neuen
legislaturperiode dass wir eben auch
entsprechend hier die attraktivität
steigern psychologische unterstützung
entsprechendes teambuilding die
gesundheitspolitik gilt als einer der
größten baustellen der ampelkoalition
olaf scholz hat bei seiner ersten
regierungserklärung im bundestag
angekündigt zu handeln die pflegekräfte
die frauen und männer in der pflege
haben großartiges geleistet oft über das
erträgliche hinaus ihnen gilt unser dank
wir haben deshalb ein pflege bonus
vereinbart und werden die
steuerbefreiung anheben doch wir wissen
dass das noch keine strukturelle lösung
ist darum werden wir die
arbeitsbedingungen der pflegekräfte
verbessern indem wir eine bessere
personalausstattung in krankenhäusern
möglich machen
wichtig ist auch dass wir die lücke
zwischen den löhnen der kranken und
altenpflege schließen es ist wichtig und
gut dass das thema aufmerksamkeit
bekommt und die regierung handeln will
aber wie immer gibt es auch zweifel und
den wunsch nach konkreten maßnahmen
franken sie wieder des dankes für die
pflegerinnen und pfleger auch
ankündigungen hat man wieder gehört dass
kennen die pflegerinnen und pfleger
bereits zur genüge noch aus ihrer zeit
als vizekanzler
ankündigungen reichen nicht aus ein
versuch ist das tv wg das gesetz zur
weiterentwicklung der
gesundheitsversorgung
teile des gesetzes sind schon 2020 in
kraft getreten ab september
2022 kommt und eine tarifliche
entlohnung dazu dann dürfen nur noch
pflegeeinrichtungen zur versorgung
zugelassen werden die ihre pflege und
betreuungskräfte nach tarif bezahlen
dafür hat allerdings noch die große
koalition gesorgt auch wenn bemühungen
um einen bundesweiten tarifvertrag
gescheitert waren trotzdem hat das ganze
schon jetzt positive auswirkungen
sind ja schon lange im beruf aber ich
habe in den letzten 12 bis 18 monaten
eine entwicklung erlebt haben die ich in
meinen kühnsten träumen nicht für
möglich gehalten habe wo sich die
gehälter wirklich unglaublich gesteigert
haben am lohn wird also zumindest
geschraubt das allein wird aber nicht
reichen anerkennung fallpauschalen
bessere bedingungen und psychologische
betreuung dafür müssen antworten
gefunden werden und zwar jetzt
denn in der archivrecherchen kontext hat
sich gezeigt viele pflegekräfte lieben
ihren beruf man muss es ihnen aber
ermöglichen ihnen auch gut ausführen zu
können
direkte positive bestätigung haben sich
an die fragen warum was mache ich hier
wohne ich dass das geklappt hat und ich
will es wieder machen wenn ihr mehr zu
dem thema sehen wollt dann schaut euch
doch hier das video von unseren
kolleginnen von ultraviolet stories zu
sexuellen belästigung von pflegekräften
an und hier noch eine folge kontext mit
meinem kollegen theo koll der das thema
klimaschutz in den kontext gesetzt hat